>> PRESIDENT BIDEN THREATENING
CONSEQUENCES BEFORE HIS BIG
PHONE CALL WITH CHINA'S
PRESIDENT TODAY WARNING THE
COMMUNIST COUNTRY AGAINST
HELPING OUT RUSSIA'S INVASION.
NOW THAT THE CALL IS OVER, THE
WHITE HOUSE SAID PRESIDENT BIDEN
DID NOT MAKE ANY SPECIFIC
REQUESTS OF CHINA.
BUT, INSTEAD, LAID OUT HIS
ASSESSMENT OF THE SITUATION.
GREAT.
>> PRESIDENT BIDEN WASN'T MAKING
SPECIFIC REQUESTS OF CHINA.
WHY NOT?
AND GIVEN THE SPACE HERE.
>> BECAUSE CHINA HAS TO MAKE A
DECISION FOR THEMSELVES ABOUT
WHERE THEY WANT B TO STAND AND
HOW THEY WANT THE HISTORY BOOKS
TO LOOK AT THEM AND VIEW THEIR
ACTIONS.
AND THAT IS A DECISION FOR
PRESIDENT XI AND TB THE CHINESE
TO MAKE.
>> CAN YOU OFFER ANY EXPLANATION
WHY THERE ARE CONCERNS AFTER
THIS CALL?
>> WE WILL CONTINUE TO WATCH
UNTIL WE SEE WHAT ACTIONS THEY
TAKE OR DON'T TAKE.
>> JESSE, IN SCIENTIFIC TERMS,
THAT'S CALLED A GARBAGE ANSWER.
ARE THEY NOT TAKING THIS
SERIOUSLY?
A TWO-HOUR PHONE CALL AND THEY
DIDN'T TALK ABOUT HOW TO STOP
PUTIN, JUST MAKE AN ASSESSMENT.
WHAT A WASTE OF TIME.
>> I CAN'T BELIEVE SHE SAID, THE
CHINESE HAVE TO DECIDE HOW THEY
WANT THE HISTORY BOOKS -- CHINA
WRITES THEIR OWN HISTORY BOOKS.
NOT LIKE A WORLD HISTORY.
COME ON, JEN.
THAT SEEMS TO BE LIKE THE
PRESSURE POINT.
THAT'S WHAT THEY SAY ABOUT PUTIN
AND CUBA.
THE HISTORY BOOKS.
WHAT ABOUT RIGHT NOW?
I DON'T KNOW HOW WELL JOE DID ON
THAT CALL.
I DON'T THINK HE DID VERY WELL.
THEY GIVE HIM NOTES AND HE LOOKS
AND -- HE'S NOT A COMMANDING
PRESENCE.
SO THAT MADE ME NERVOUS.
HE HAS A PRETTY EASY TASK.
CHINA SCREWED UP.
THEY HITCHED THEIR WAGON TO A
LOSER.
NO WAY RUSSIA WINS THIS THING.
AND CHINA LOOKS REALLY BAD NOW.
XI IS SCREWED.
HE PRESTIGE ON THE LINE FOR
PUTIN.
HE'S SUPPOSED TO BE A BIG
STATESMAN, THE RISING POWER.
EVERYBODY DISGUST WITH HIS BOY
AND HE HAS TO SLOWLY BACK OUT OF
THE JAM HE'S IN.
HE GETS ON THE HORN WITH BIDEN.
BIDEN PROBABLY LET HIM OFF OF
THE HOOKMENT. HE SHOULD HAVE
BEEN MUCH TOUGHER.
I WASN'T THERE.
I'M SURMISING, HE WASN'T TOUGH
ENOUGH.
YOU HAVE TO SEPARATE THE TWO
WEASELS, THE RUSSIANS FROM THE
CHINESE AND YOU DO THAT WITH
TOUGH TALK AND THREATS AND DO IT
WITH ECONOMIC THREATS.
AND I DON'T THINK BIDEN PLAYED
THAT CARD.
>> DAGUEN, WE WORRY THAT, YOU
KNOW, RUSSIA IS GOING TO BE
TETHERED TO CHINA.
BUT DOESN'T CHINA NEED AMERICA
AND EUROPE MORE THAN IT NEEDS
RUSSIA?
WE BUY SO MUCH FROM THEM.
RUSSIA DOESN'T BUY MUCH OF
ANYTHING.
>> CHINA KNOWS WE'RE SUCKERS AND
SOFT.
NOT ALL AMERICANS, BUT THAT WE
ARE DEPENDENT ON THEIR CHEAP
IMPORTED GOODS.
AND "THE WALL STREET JOURNAL"
PHRASED IT AS THEISH THIS IS NOT
JUST CHINA AND RUSSIA.
THIS IS CHINA AND RUSSIA AND
INDIA AND EVEN SAUDI ARABIA THAT
IS TRYING TO MOVE AWAY FROM A
WESTERN-DOMINATED WORLD.
IN TERMS OF POWER, IN TERMS OF
ECONOMIC HEFT.
I CALL IT THE -- ON YOUR
SHOW,INGS THE RAPID FIRE
REALIGNMENT OF WORLD POWER.
IT IS THE JOURNAL DESCRIBED IT,
THE EDITORIAL PAGE AS A UNION OF
A NATION THAT ARE HOSTILE TO
DEMOCRACY, ECONOMIC FREEDOM, AND
U.S. LEADERSHIP.
AND CHINA IS LINING UP WITH
SAUDI ARABIA.
SAUDI ARABIA WON'T TAKE JOE
BIDEN'S CALLS, BUT SAUDI ARABIA
MAY AGREE TO CHINA PAYING FOR
ITS OIL IN THE YUAN.
CHINA GETS NATURAL RESOURCES
FROM RUSSIA, PERIOD.
AND LI
IT WILL BE A R
CHINA'S GROWTH.
OUR SOFTNESS -- WE RUN UP OUR
DEBT SO MUCH.
130% DEBT TO GDP, WE DON'T HAVE
THE MONEY TO TAKE ON CHINA AT
THIS POINT.
WE'RE SO SOFT THAT THE DEMOCRATS
IN CALIFORNIA ARE SENDING $400
CHECKS TO PEOPLE TO OFFSET THE
HIGH GAS PRICES AND PEOPLE DON'T
EVEN HAVE CARS OR DRIVE GET
THEM.
WE'RE NOT ABLE TO STAND AND CUT
OFF SUPPLIES FROM CHINA.
WE'RE --
>> I WOULD HAVE DONE
SOMETHING -- I'M SORRY.
I WOULD HAVE SAID, LISTEN, XI,
OR HOWEVER YOU SAY HIS NAME, I
WOULD HAVE SAID, YOU'RE NOT
GETTING ANYMORE VISAS.
NO MORE CHINESE ARE GOING TO
COME TO THIS COUNTRY AND STEAL
SECRETS AND RIP OFF INTELLECTUAL
PROPERTY.
AND IF YOU SUPPLY ARMS TO THE
KREMLIN, THAT'S WHAT HAPPENS.
THAT'S THEIR WHOLE ECONOMY.
THAT'S THE ONLY WAY THEY
SURVIVE.
>> WHAT DO YOU THINK, JESSICA?
>> I THINK JESSE STOLE TIME FROM
ME AND THE JUDGE.
>> YOU WILL GET IT BACK IN THE
SECOND HALF.
>> OH, I WILL GET IT BACK.
>> IN THE HUNTER SEGMENT.
>> YOU CAN TALK ALL THE WAY --
>> THIS IS MORE OF THIS -- OKAY.
FROM THE READOUT WE GOT, IT DOES
SAY PRESIDENT BIDEN DESCRIBED
THE IMPLICATIONS AND
CONSEQUENCES IF CHINA SUPPLIES
MATERIAL SUPPORT TO RUSSIA.
PRESIDENT XI SAID A WAR IN
UKRAINE IS IN NO ONE'S INTLES,
HE SUPPORTS PEACE.
THIS IS DEVELOPED TO SUCH A
POINT THAT CHINA DOESN'T WANT TO
SEE IT.
NOW, HE IS STILL MORE RUSSIA'S
FRIEND THAN OUR FRIEND.
IT'S CLEAR.
HE DOESN'T WANT IT.
HE SAID IT'S ON THE U.S. AND
NATO TO BROKER THIS DEAL.
BUT THAT MAKES SENSE.
>> HE SAID THAT?
>> I SHOULD HAVE READ THAT.
>> HE PUT THAT ON US?
>> HE PUT IT ON US.
>> HE SAID THAT?
>> ARE YOU KIDDING ME?
HE SAID THAT BECAUSE
FUNDAMENTALLY FOR PUTIN, THIS IS
ABOUT UKRAINE WANTING TO BE PART
OF OUR SYSTEM, AND NOT PART OF
PUTIN'S SYSTEM.   SO, THAT SEEMS
LIKE A GOOD CALL.
I KNOW YOU WOULD HAVE DONE
BETTER, BUT IT SEEMS GOOD TO ME.
>> JUDGE, CAN WE PLAY
ALTERNATE -- ALTERNATE HISTORY?
IF TRUMP WERE PRESIDENT.
>> LET ME SAY THIS, IF TRUMP
WERE PRESIDENT, WE WOULDN'T HAVE
HAD THAT MEETING.
WHERE EVERYBODY JUST REPEATED
THEIR OWN TALKING POINTS.
THIS WAS NOTHING MORE THAN A
FACE-TO-FACE PHOTO OP.
THAT'S ALL IT WAS.
BIDEN GOT NOTHING OUT OF IT.
HE DIDN'T GET XI TO SAY, GEE,
YOU'RE RIGHT, JOE, I'M WITH YOU
AND ALL OF THIS.
ALL THEY SAID, ALL CHINA SAID
WAS, LOOK, WE DON'T LIKE
CONFRONTATION.
WE DON'T BELIEVE IN WAR.
BUT DO THEY CONDEMN UKRAINE --
DO THEY CONDEMN RUSSIA FOR
ATTACKING UKRAINE?
ABSOLUTELY NOT.
THEN THEY SAY CHINA TELLS US.
THEY MAKE IT CLEAR.
THEY SAY CHINA WANTS THE U.S. TO
PROMISE -- THIS IS IN THE
READOUT TOO, THAT THERE WILL BE
NO CONFLICT IF THEY TAKE TAIWAN,
WHICH IS THEIR STRATEGIC
OBJECTIVE.
AND THAT'S A PROBLEM FOR US.
BECAUSE 85% OF OUR CHIPS ARE
MADE IN TAIWAN AND WE RELY ON
THEM.
SO, YOU KNOW, THE CHINESE ARE
BLAMING US FOR RUSSIA INVADING
UKRAINE BECAUSE -- AND NOW
IT'S -- JESSICA IS RIGHT.
THE UNITED STATES AND NATO HAVE
TO GO TO -- GO TO PUTIN AND TELL
HIM TO STOP.
BY THE WAY, CONSEQUENCES,
ACCORDING TO JOE BIDEN, TO CHINA
IS IF THEY PROVIDE MATERIAL
SUPPORT TO RUSSIA.
WHAT IS MATERIAL?
IS IT ECONOMIC?
IS IT FINANCIAL?
BY THE WAY, JOE, IF YOU WANT TO
DISCONNECT THE UNITED STATES
FROM CHINA, STOP AMERICAN
COMPANIES GOING OVER THERE AND
MANUFACTURING ALL KINDS OF
AMERICAN GOODS IN CHINA?
WHY DON'T YOU MAKE IT A NEGATIVE
FOR THEM TO DO THAT?
WHY ARE OUR MEDICINES BEING MADE
IN CHINA?
WHY DON'T YOU COME UP WITH
SOMETHING IF YOU BACK AMERICA SO
WE CAN MANUFACTURE IN THE UNITED
STATES.
>> WE HAVEN'T GOTTEN ANSWERS AS
TO WHY THE WAR WAS --
>> THE FLU WAS RELEASED BY --
UNLEASED ON THE WORLD AND WE
DON'T HAVE ANSWERS ABO